Okay. You want to learn about the future?
It's the future is now.
Because this morning,
a new artificial intelligence to
known as ChatGPT
gained popularity
for its ability to craft emails,
write research papers
and answer
almost any question
in a matter of seconds.
It is a powerful new technology
with extraordinary potential,
but there are also warnings
about the huge risk of misuse.
You know, who knows all about th
Vanessa Quick, she joins us now.
Good morning.
Sounds interesting and interesti
but with caution.
Intriguing, certainly.
And a lot of analysts
say it's as revolutionary as the
But some say it's a threat to so
But one thing is for sure,
it's sparking interest
among everyone from top CEOs to
chat, graffiti,
short for chat, generative.
Pre-training Transformer is a ma
learning model that can generate
humanlike text.
It's been trained
on a massive amount of data,
allowing it to understand and re
to a wide range of questions.
And prompts.
What you just heard me reading
wasn't written by me.
It was written by artificial int
chat GPT.
I simply typed in a prompt
write a TV news script
written by a reporter about chat
And in just seconds, the
AI spit out the copy you just he
she beat has exploded
in popularity in recent months.
CEOs are now using it to write e
It even passed a Wharton
School of Business exam
Should people be more excited ab
or more fearful of it?
I think we should have a mixed y
open API
which owns
Chat GPT
says the technology
is still in its research phase
and can produce inaccurate infor
You like artificial intelligence
but are you here to issue
a warning about it?
Absolutely.
Artificial intelligence
is sort of like a teenager right
It's exciting to see the teenage
get its footing,
but it's also not there yet,
and we can't trust it.
But Microsoft thinks it's a good
Even with some risks,
they're investing billions
of dollars in open AI
Jack Poe, CEO of Ansible
Health, had GPT take three versi
of the U.S.
medical licensing test,
and it passed all three.
Not only can
I answer very complex questions,
it can also modulate its answer.
Poe and his team of 30 doctors s
using the platform
to help with treatment
for their patients
who have COPD, a pulmonary disea
What this technology could reall
and has already started enabling
is to suddenly suggest things
that we might not be thinking of
It will absolutely save lives
Jake Heller is a lawyer
and founder of Case Text,
which helps its clients comb
through documents using A.I.
like Chat CBT.
You can have it read a police re
You can
you can have it
see if witnesses
give contradictory testimony.
You can almost certainly help
find information
that is pertinent to
your guilt or innocence.
But Poe and Heller
both say that human oversight of
is still necessary.
OpenAI says the platform can pro
harmful instructions in law.
There absolutely is right
and wrong answers.
And that's why, you know, Chatty
alone is not going to be enough
some of the most important quest
and feels like law.
And then there's
the question of plagiarism.
New York City
Public Schools
Banned Chat
on school
network devices
due to concerns
about negative impacts
on student
learning and concerns
regarding the safety
and accuracy of content.
It's incredible innovation
At the same time,
it's like opening a Pandora's Bo
Which is why Edward Tien,
a 22 year old Princeton student
spent his winter break building
which he says can detect
whether something
is likely written by a human or
He says teachers
use it to check their students p
Is this like one a I
cross-checking another?
In a sense.
Yeah.
But can it spot misinformation?
Oh, okay. Yeah.
So as opposed to misinformation,
more of like
I can only spot
if something is 18
or eight or human generated.
And that's the greatest fear of
Spreading misinformation.
Chat bot
a tool designed to help humanity
could ultimately hurt it.
People who want to manipulate el
and things like that,
instead of
like writing one thing at a time
we could be able to write
thousands of things
to give for example, vaccine den
more oxygen than it deserves.
And Gary Marcus, you just heard
from there, has written books
about artificial intelligence.
He has founded companies
He says we're about 75 years awa
I truly being human like until t
we need regulation and and Repre
Ted Lieu from California
he plans to introduce
legislation to create an AI comm
to oversee all of this new ideol
Because we know a lot
but we also know very little abo
Some people are passing
college courses with papers
written by Chatty Beatty. Yeah.
Just keep thinking of Space Odys
how the hell 9000.
No, I will not turn 21.
A Space Odyssey gets a little sc
We're almost there.
Thank you, Vanessa. Great report